i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about
ikey live training and how to do that
stuff so
uh this is the second part of a two-part
series first part we talked about
kumiuchi and what that was and
how we can start to train that in a live
way and now we're going to talk about uh
ikey and how to train that in a live way
and with the last video i talked a
little more about the word sparring and
use the word sparring which kind of
means to struggle
um in this we should really not be doing
a lot of struggle at least not physical
struggle so
it doesn't mean we're not going to
intellectually struggle with the right
thing to do at the right time it just
means we're ideally not going to
physically struggle with the other
person
and that's what i key actually is it's
about an energetic exchange
and not a physical exchange so i'm going
to call josh and maya here we're going
to talk about the live training that we
use in this school to work on the i keep
principles josh maya
all right so today we're going to be
talking about how to do a live training
practice
with the ikey stuff so
what is that stuff and how does it work
so uh we can't really use the word
sparring when we're talking about aikido
and because the idea is really we don't
want to struggle at least not physically
and so and that's another thing we can
kind of argue about whether
mental struggle is really struggle and
of course it is on some level but
in aikido we want to keep everything
energetic and ideally we want to have it
energetically
work together and not oppose each other
so struggle's the antithesis of what
we're trying to do
so we're trying to ideally if we're
really skilled we'd be able to to figure
out a way to always make the energies
match
that wouldn't be a struggle and
everything would come off really well so
when we're talking about that we can't
really use the word sparring anymore
we now have to use the word uh live
training and live training just means a
situation that's live you know so all
kinds of different variables could
happen
and you have to be able to act in the
moment and deal with those variables as
we go
so remember the way we break down aikido
here in the school
we have three major components one is
tai sabaki and that's how you organize
your body so that's
any way you make strength or power or
force or
step or fall down any of that stuff's
all how you personally organize your own
body
then we have aiki and ikea is the
ability to energetically interact and
kumiuchi and that's the ability to
struggle
and aikido we don't want to struggle as
a means to an end
we want to struggle only to set us back
to ikey so that's the idea we
only use kumiuch in a very limited way
so we can get back to setting up ikey
and that's what we're always working
towards
all right so today maya's going to
represent ikey for us so we're going to
have her doing all the ikey stuff
and then we're going to go through the
basic live drills all right so i think
the first thing to understand and one of
the most important lessons for an aikido
student is
what range does making ikey become
very very difficult right so
understanding that range is super super
important
so we're going to show a really simple
drill that i use all the time i use it
in my self-defense classes when i'm
talking about
just in general to people you know what
is a dangerous self-defense range and
what is an acceptable self-defense range
um and also in aikido and aikido is
where i actually got all these ideas
from so
these are the lessons of aikido um so
we're gonna talk about that first we're
gonna set up josh and maya at a really
simple distance
they're going to be at a shoulder touch
okay so now i see if josh sticks out his
hand he can touch my shoulder without
moving his body at all so he can easily
touch her shoulder
all right now from this it's going to be
real simple all josh is going to try to
do is touch my shoulder
that's it try and touch her shoulder now
understand if he could touch her
shoulder like that
that means he could hit her in the face
he could cut her with a knife he could
anything all you got to do is move his
arm then he could do all those actions
he could grab her to pull her in and
wrestle with her
whatever stuff so that's the range at
which he could do that
okay so he's only going to touch your
shoulder and what maya is going to try
to do
is always get out of the way so every
time josh tries to touch her shoulder
maya is going to just do a slow one so
we can see josh going to be right there
we go so every time he moves his hand
maya's going to try to move out of the
way so we can see that okay now josh is
going to go
freely of his own accord whenever he
wants to do it so if he can detect some
kind of rhythms or patterns maya is in
or get her at a moment she's not
expecting it if he sees she kind of
dozes off then he's going to use that
time to get her right so
he's whenever he wants to come in and
try and touch her
all right good enough okay now we could
make lots of
inferences from that right so we could
say well maya sucks at martial arts so
because she sucks at martial arts
then she needs to do more training
because josh got her every single time
if we took a large group of people and
looked at him doing this we would see
that most people get hit at that range
now the reason is because
this range is inherently dangerous there
is not a skill set you can train
at this range to make you regularly
successful
now that's not to say you can't
sometimes get out of the way but again
that's a roll of the dice and remember
we're trying to look at trained skills
things we can get better at
now the reason that it's so hard for
maya to get out of the range here
is because two reasons one josh's hand
is significantly faster than maya's foot
so when she's trying to take an action
with her foot to counter josh's action
with his hands
then it's going to be inherently slow so
we're teaching the students something
really
true and visceral at this point which is
you can't move your feet as fast as
someone can move their hands okay now
we could of course add to this that maya
could block so let's say josh comes in
to hit her and maya blocks okay now
that's very reasonable maya can use
her hand speed to match josh's hand
speed however the problem with this is
maya just doesn't have much reaction
time in this
now if she trained a whole lot and maybe
had a better reaction time than josh has
to to make his action happen
she might be able to kind of get closer
to 50 50 or so
but in truth if this guy is at all close
to her ability level
he'll always win because he is acting
first
first person to act is generally going
to win the situation
so we're teaching them something else
really important that reacting is
slower than acting right and that's an
important thing to understand
so two good things come out of this
drill and it's a very live drill
one is that your hand moves way faster
than the foot
and two is that reaction time is slower
than
action time right so so we learned that
all right now
that being said as iq students we're not
going to spend much time working at this
range and in fact we're going to learn
that we
hate this range the reason we hate this
range is because
it's unlikely that we're going to be
successful at this range
this range is for different kinds of
martial arts right so
studying boxing for this kind of range
and arguably those guys are always
trying to stay out of that range except
for when they want to be in that range
studying grappling is good for this kind
of range right so other martial arts
which
are very valid and good to study there's
nothing wrong with selling other martial
arts
are better for this range than aikido is
so now we got to figure out what an
aikido acceptable range is all right now
we have the aikido ma eye and this is
the classic
eye that everyone learns first day of
aikido class you go into an aikido
school
and this is probably one of the very
first lessons you learned and again
we're going to have a game they play at
this range right which is
they're both going to measure out this
distance now we're going to play the
exact same game we did a second ago josh
is gonna try to hit my shoulder and
maya's gonna try to get out of the way
as fast and as erratic as he wants to be
he can go
okay now we're already seeing something
very different
now we could infer from that josh sucks
he needs to learn to hit
faster and move faster and all that
stuff and of course he could always get
better at that we could all get better
at things
but something else if we looked at a big
group of people doing this
we would learn that generally as long as
the person receiving
is attentive they can get out of the way
now the reason they can get out of the
way again is twofold
because josh can't just use his hand he
has to move his foot
maya can move her foot as well and that
means they're going to be in equal time
so
if josh moves his foot and maya moves
her foot they're in equal time
the second thing and arguably more
important is that
maya has enough reaction time to deal
with this situation right so
she actually can cognitively figure out
what's going on and deal with that
before he can get to her this gives you
a fighting
chance now if we go beyond this range we
will just skew
maya's advantages more and more and more
and so it gets to where you know if
they're really far apart she can
definitely see what's coming way before
it ever gets there right that is the
first
live training drill for i key that your
students have to get you have to
inherently understand
what maw eye is okay now the second
drill you need to work with with the
guys
is what happens if the person can
encroach on that distance okay
now this is not a live training drill at
all but it's a way to start slowly
easing your students into something
that's later gonna become a very fast
uh progression as josh is gonna come in
towards maya with his hands extended
just like a frankenstein or zombie and
maya is going to suppress the arm and
get out of the way
all right there we go so real simple now
there are six
ways in in aikido in which we can do
this so in this school we use six tai no
hinko six
body variations position variations and
we can use all six of those now five of
those are
outside moving right so what we mean by
that is here's a if we drew a line
between them
five of those uh tai no hinko are going
to move outside the line and only one of
those is going to move inside the line
so that one's special so first we're
just going to hit the five basic outside
okay so as josh comes in towards maya
mike can practice a 45
she can practice an outside turn also
okay so mike can practice
a45 good mike can practice eating me
good maya can practice a 90.
good and mike can practice a triangle
all right so there's her five outside
right so she has a 45 she has an outside
turn
she has a triangle step she has a 90
and she has edema eating me right so
those five are five
outside steps she's going to use okay
now we have one inside step now this
inside step until you kind of understand
how aikido theory works
seems stupid because she's actually
going to turn inside the
line and without an adaptation and just
don't put your arms out let's just show
what that looks like so
this is an inside turn okay that's an
inside turn now if you look at that and
go real slow so they can see that so is
josh is coming in
my actually turns inside of josh turning
her back towards josh and this seems
like a crazy movement
a maya can adapt any of the outside tai
no hinko to an
inside dino hinko so let's say maya just
tries only tries
an outside turn and josh is wise to that
and he moves from a narrow attack to a
wide attack as she does that it would
look like this
right okay so what happened was maya's
trying to suppress and get to the
outside of the line and josh went around
her suppression
and made a wide attack like this so he
could grithe her up right so he can kind
of get her
get all around her like this now maya
can turn that into an
inside turn so watch now she'll turn the
outside turn into an inside turn watch
how this happens
so as josh is going around maya scoots
underneath his arm
right now we can do that from an outside
turn we can also do that from edemi
we could also do that from a triangle
we could also do that from a 90.
and we can also do that from a 45.
all right so this leads us to another
drill that i like to run with people
when we start learning how to make
good eye key and and this is you know
not great ikea because in fact he's
already crouched
in the distance he's gotten too close to
her so it's not great but how can she
make energetic actions that fit with
what josh is doing
and this is an adaptation drill so as
we're doing this what we'll have them do
is
josh will come at maya sometimes only
staying narrow
and she should just use outside
movements for that we got five outside
movements that should work for that so
every time he comes narrow that's what
she should do
he's gonna randomly put in adaptations
so to go from narrow to wide
and when he does that mine needs to
train herself to skate right around that
action
now what you want to do with your
students is have them do this randomly
right so
after they can do both of those
variations they need to do it randomly
so this person gets used to
if they make successful outside movement
then it's just successful
but if there's adaptation they start
learning how to adapt to that adaptation
let's run a little bit more
all right good so understand we still
have the training wheels on at this
point this is still
super mellow practice but we're getting
our students used to moving in away with
each other that will train them for
later faster action will help them move
in
in those kinds of ways all right now in
this josh is doing a really
simple practice to get around maya
suppression so
um let's just kind of fake it so as josh
comes in and might get suppression
there josh all josh has to do right now
is move his arm around and now he's in a
wide position he can get to maya right
but my josh could do all kinds of stuff
he could pull his arm out and shoot it
back in real fast he could shoot his
other arm across there's all kinds of
ways in which he could try and grab maya
so the next drill house let's have you
say guys separate again the next drill
out is going to be a suppression drill
and what this drill is designed to do is
to teach maya how to keep the best
suppression possible
so now as josh comes in he's going to
always try to get around her suppression
and get maya
and maya is always going to try to keep
josh from getting her so as josh comes
in he tried to reach around really far
that time
he stopped for a second and paused and
grabbed
and he got her that one all right good
and that showed us something all right
good okay so that time he snuck out
there and he got her shoulder
and maya quickly used a hadoki technique
to get free okay
now hidoki will be in our kumiuchi
series we put some videos out on hidoki
so we can look that up
but i would recommend stacking those
together so when your students get
grabbed and they didn't expect
someone to get around their suppression
they quickly made hidoki and you can see
maya just instantly went into hidoki and
she got free and that's what we should
be training in aikido
okay so that drill what it's designed to
do is to teach the aikido student how to
have an
active and live suppression so when maya
and let's just kind of fake it here so
when maya gets our hand on josh's arm
let's have you go to the other side
actually there we go so when maya gets
her hand on josh's arm
understand josh could do lots of stuff
with his hand he could go back he could
go up he could go down and do all kinds
of stuff
and mine needs to learn to have active
suppression with that right okay now the
second part what josh was just showing
right now
is josh could reach from the other side
and so that's why maya always has to be
trying to move to the outside of this
right
and that deals with that now we see
there classic ikkyo from aikido so why
is ikyo aikido's first lesson
well there it is because it's our main
suppression method right and maya can
use that to keep josh away from it all
right very good
so first we're going to go through the
basic taino hinko after they understand
my eye we're going through the basic
taino hinko and then we're going to go
to an active suppression drill
now one thing we're going to try not to
have josh do there is stop
and the reason is because anytime
someone stops in aikido an attacker
stops
you should just make distance right so
maya doesn't want to play a game so
let's
show this kind of game so let's say josh
comes in for that wait hang on one
second let's say josh comes in for the
active suppression drill
and he stops to catch maya and plays the
game maya could dance with him like this
okay that's stupid it's bad it's
horrible aikido because
if you notice they were in the range
that we talked about earlier was bad for
aikido
so maya knowing that that range is bad
for aikido should tell maya that every
time they do that she should do this in
fact
all right so now you see that end up
we're going to have the same thing we
just had a second ago before josh stop
is josh going to have to run to get maya
because maya's making distance
so that's the way that's dealt with in
this practice if the attacker
wants to stop and play this game then
the defender should just walk away from
them
and then that will force the attacker to
chase them and again we'll have up the
exact situation that we just set up
right now
so with your guys when you see that
going on too much you can explain that
to them and you can say hey guys
we're not running all around the mat
right now we're practicing it in a
straight line because we still have the
training wheels on right so this is
still
we're still baby stepping it here okay
so that's how you deal with those
problems that are going to come up in
your life practice i will warn you now
they will come up quite often
all right so the next drill we're going
to work from this is going to require a
weapon
all right so now we got a pool noodle of
doom
all right so actually because we're
having maya do the i key we're gonna go
ahead and switch this
all right so one of the other lessons in
aikido is a certain point so much force
has been brought that there's no way you
can escape not using a weapon because
you have to have some force of your own
to counter the amazing force that this
person's being bringing and that could
be just because they're physically so
much greater than you
right so if you're fighting a pro mma
fighter you're going to need a weapon in
your hand
if you're not a pro mma fighter there's
no way you're going to deal with that
guy
without a weapon in your hand so let's
just pretend josh is a pro mma fighter
the only way he might is possibly going
to deal with josh is to have a weapon
right so
we need to train those skills now a
really unobviously difficult thing
is moving and using a weapon at the same
time right so
you might think oh of course i'll just
zig and zag and hit people with weapons
it'll be so sweet
you won't do that until you train it a
lot you will suck at it we all have many
times
because it's difficult to think of how
to get away and how to hit someone at
the same time it's a real skill that has
to be trained
maya is going to do the basic drill we
did before but she's going to use the
weapon as she does that so as josh comes
in she's going to get suppression tai no
hinko and use the weapon
okay now notice there she used the
weapon for the suppression acceptable
there she used her hand for suppression
and attacked with the weapon acceptable
so this is just the same drill except
we're
forcing maya to start to learn how to
use a weapon while she's making
suppression and tai no hinko so this is
another skill she's going to use
okay now then again of course we can add
to this josh trying to get around her
suppression and maya using a defense
good okay so with that we can see that
uh josh is trying to come in he's trying
to get around her suppression she's
trying to hit now again if you get your
students doing the little dance thing
you should just be telling the nage that
their objective is to get away from the
dance thing right so
okay so josh if josh comes in towards
maya
and he stops to do the little dance okay
and then maya plays the dance and she
starts popping him with the stick
right so okay that's not the game of
aikido right so maya should already know
that that range is bad for her because
we learned that in those early ma eye
drills so maya doesn't want to be at
that range
she wants the most range because she has
the most i keep potential with that so
if josh plays the dance game
then that's what maya should do she
should go away now of course the second
maya walks away
if josh wants to get her he'll have to
chase her and again we're at this basic
setup for this drill
so doing that little dance game is just
a way not to practice the thing that
we're practicing
right now now later we can open it up
and we will in just a second here with
rondori and we can let them do whatever
they want and then it will be a
completely free practice and we'll see
how the dance game plays out for josh
but in this drill you need to keep your
students really really honest with this
right so now from this we should be able
to judge good distance for our students
we should be able to make suppression
and tai no hinko for our students we
should be able to use a weapon making
taino hinko and suppression for our
students and so now that's going to
bring us to rondori
okay so i'm going to get out of here in
a second we're going to let these guys
go but we'll set up a box and the box is
the parameters maya has to be in right
so that's cor
it's totally artificial but it
represents her being in a room or in a
situation where there's dangerous
things on the edges right so maybe
there's a cliff or a road or a pool or
whatever stuff she doesn't want to get
in so mine's got to manage the distance
so she doesn't get knocked out of bounds
and she has to keep her stick while
she's doing that to use it on josh
josh isn't going to feign that he's
getting hurt because that's not the
objective of this
all we're training maya to do is use her
weapon while she's moving now josh of
course his win
criteria in this is going gonna be he
takes the weapon away from her or she
drops it even she drops it on her own
that's a win criteria for josh
he pushes her out of bounds that's a win
criteria for josh
he knocks her down so anything other
than her feet are on the ground
that's a win criteria for josh because
aikido doesn't train that stuff right so
we should get up from there right so
that's a win criteria for josh the only
way maya wins is to survive the whole
time okay
we're going to run these in 10 second
intervals right now and 10 seconds is
i wouldn't go any longer for your
students than 10 seconds in the
beginning
10 seconds is a lot and the amount of
damage this guy would usually acquire in
10 seconds will be significant because
remember she's using a weapon the whole
time so it was a pistol she'd be putting
rounds on target
if it's a stick she's whacking him it's
a knife she's cutting him so that's 10
seconds is a lot of time for him to
sustain continuous injury
[Music]
all right guys so that was uh the drills
i would recommend beginning your
students off working with
ikea live training so um
most of those practices or a lot of
those practices aren't actually live
practices but you're going to need to do
them to build up to the wrong dory we
had at the end
so that's the way we do rondori we would
generally do it with two attackers
although
just to make things easy and uh we did
it with just the two today
two people total instead of having three
total which two attackers and one nugget
so um we did it that way just so it was
easier to see and consistent with what
we did but
generally when you get into wrongdoing
you need to start doing multiple
attackers
there's another set of drills that you
need to work on for multiple attackers
we'll make a video we've kind of made
some videos in the past but we'll make
some more videos for you guys talking
about multiple attacker rondori and how
you start to work that
but you can see in there what's trying
to happen now understand that when
maya's in the wrong dory situation that
is not
ideal aikido that's right before failing
aikido so
she doesn't want to be there she doesn't
have to use a weapon she doesn't want to
be having to move around real fast with
a guy like that it's dangerous and the
more skilled josh is
the less likely she is going to be able
to deal with that so honestly good iq
would be never being in that situation
but that's right before it's going to
turn into serious kumiuchi so
once josh gets ahold of her then we're
already into kumuchi range and
and this is about ikey so that
progression will build your students up
so remember first work on
my eye they have to understand my eye
and what's a good distance for ikea and
what's a bad distance for aikido
if you understand what a good distance
for aikido is that will fix a lot of the
problems your students are going to have
because they'll automatically always be
resetting to the good distance right
the good distance is just really far
away that's the best distance you can
have
but that minimum fingertip distance
that's the last distance you can
possibly do reasonable eye key
then after they can judge that distance
really well you'd have them work with
tyno hinko and suppression so
how do you suppress the arm and get off
the line that's going to be really key
then how do you adapt to what they're
going to do so when you suppress their
arm they're not just going to
be like a zombie or a frankenstein and
keep their arms out they're going to
move their arms around to try and get
you so you have to have an adaptive
drill
and it's a pretty live drill now because
the person's actually trying to come
around and get you
still there's a lot of things though
that are off the table in that and i
explain the reasons why because
stopping wouldn't be working on that
skill set when we get into wrongdoing
josh could do whatever he wanted
now understand in that rondori josh just
attacked because he has 10 seconds to
try and get maya so he's explosively
attacking
and that's also the mindset of someone
who's just furious and they're coming at
you to get you right so there's not a
well planned out game there there's just
josh wanting to get maya as fast as
possible
and that's just like a violent attack
where someone's trying to get you now if
you have ninjas who are plotting to get
you all the time you need other training
other than what you're going to get in a
regular dojo this is for
a situation where someone just got
violently all of a sudden and they want
to attack you and how do you deal with
that so
that's what we envision as a real life
scenario you know you're talking to
someone and everything seemed cool and
then all of a sudden they freak out and
they attack you how do you deal with
that situation
now that maya was really inhibited i
wouldn't i wouldn't start off with a box
this small for you guys
right so this is a really advanced box
this box is about 10 feet by 8 feet so
that's a tiny room that's like a little
bitty bedroom right so
so if you're in that kind of room and
someone starts to get hostile you should
just automatically know to get out of
the room because it's gonna be hard to
keep your distance so
if you can deal with that for 10 seconds
you're pretty skilled right so
that's you're buying yourself a lot of
time in a really uh compromised
situation
so we usually start off with the box
being somewhere around 20 by 20
and that's a good it's still still super
challenging at that speed
um if i'm working with brand new
students sometimes i'll give them the
whole mat and our mats like
uh 40 something feet by 30 something
feet so it's a pretty big match so
i'll let them use the whole mat right to
get used to that but
as the students become more and more
skilled at it you want to give them
tinier and tinier areas so that way they
have to learn
good taino hinko good suppression and
make all that work for him so
that's the progression we use that's
what we would call raw dory which you
just saw there at the end we would
usually do it with two attackers instead
of one but that's what we call rondori
and that's our skill set to build up to
live training
with ikey and in aikido being about ikey
that's the main objective we want to
practice
alright thanks a lot for watching i'm
christopher hines